concluye el plazo para que las
organizaciones políticas desarrollarán
sus procesos de democracia interna y
presentarán a su candidatos becaron las
elecciones generales anticipadas del 20
de agosto de 2023 que aspiran a la
presidencia vicepresidencia de la
república Y asambleístas luego que el
presidente de la república Guillermo
lasso aplicará la figura constitucional
de la muerte Cruzada y convocará a
elecciones generales anticipadas para
finalizar el actual periodo hasta el año
2025 en esta carrera electoral hasta
ahora ocho precandidatos han expresado
su intención de correr por la
presidencia de la República y deberán
superar el filtro del Consejo Nacional
electoral no poseer contratos con el
estado no tener sentencias condenatorias
por peculado deudores de pensiones
alimenticias y poseeres en paraísos
Fiscales entre otros requisitos que
deben cumplir los candidatos siete
hombres y una mujer aspiran a la
presidencia de la República y el
economista y experto en seguridad Jean
topic por el partido social cristiano
Luisa González quien fue funcionaria del
correísmo y es exasambleísta del
parlamento disuelto yacu Pérez por su
segunda carrera la presidencia y en este
caso no irá por el apoyo del movimiento
indígena pachakuti el ex asambleísta
Fernando villavicencio es un actor
político muy visible y el ex asambleísta
Daniel Novoa el ex vicepresidente de
Lenin Moreno ottonster que ya cuenta con
un pasado político y será su primera
carrera a una campaña electoral Javier
Baz es un empresario quien va por su
segundo intento la presidencia y Bolívar
el mismo quien es un abogado de
profesión y listo con el correísmo hasta
el año 2021 a ellos se suman siete
candidatas a la vicepresidencia y un
candidato a la vicepresidencia quien
repite antes de Zaragoza la segunda
magistratura será el domingo seis de
agosto cuando se conozca el listado
oficial de la candidaturas de por parte
del órgano electoral para la presidencia
de la república